breaking overnight the u.s. and South
Korea are analyzing North Korea's launch
of several projectiles the South Korean
military says they were launched from
North Korea's East Coast and flew
several miles before landing in the
ocean Elizabeth Palmer is in Tokyo
tracking developments Liz good morning
at about nine o'clock this morning North
Korea fired several what's being called
projectiles from a base near the East
Coast town of one son the Pentagon and
arms experts are now studying satellite
data to pinpoint exactly what these
weapons were but the evidence so far
suggests that they were short-range
rockets that flew about a hundred and
twenty five miles out over the sea
unlike the long-range ballistic missiles
the North Koreans tested in 2017 these
Rockets cannot threaten the United
States however they could hit South
Korea there's no doubt the launch is a
message it's not so clear who it's
addressed to the North Korean regime may
be signaling its frustration with the US
over stalled negotiations to swap
sanctions relief for denuclearization
talks between president Trump and kim
jeong-hoon ended in a stalemate last
February the launch may also be designed
to show North Korea's anger with the
South Koreans for participating in two
weeks of joint military exercises with
the US Air Force the White House has
responded to the news with a brief
statement saying it was aware of North
Korea's actions and would continue to
monitor as necessary Japan's foreign
minister spoke with Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo today and confirmed that the
North Korean launch didn't pose a
security risk to his country but of
course all the countries in this region
will be watching very closely to see if
this is just the beginning of even more
provocative actions by North Korea
Anthony Elizabeth Palmer thank you Liz